i didn't execute i always should have um
and perform well enough for for this
team and
you're going against the reigning super
bowl champs who are 15 and 1 and the
number one seed arrowhead and you don't
have your 18
you're not going to win the game and
um
you know that's that's what it that's
what it was you know just a couple of
decisions early on
trying to press i think in the second
half we kind of got things going a
little bit better
but our red zone efficiency
sudden for field goals when you gotta
score touchdowns against these guys
that's basically it
right around the two-minute mark it
looked like um you were just staring and
seeing seeing it all unfold just
wondering i'm sure a lot of different
emotions were running through your head
but what what uh was the number one
thing that was going through your mind
at that point
i'm obviously a lot of emotion um
anytime you don't
finish the season with the win
i feel like
that's the type of emotion you're going
to have
but the way it ended you know it doesn't
sit right with me the how chippy and
ticky tacky gotten
and i'm disappointed myself that i let
my emotions get to be there
it's not how you're supposed to play the
game of football and
all the other stuff it is what it is but
you know i need to control what i can
control and
i did there late in the fourth
it's just not good football
what's sort of just the magnitude of
playing in tom brady against the game in
a game like this
yeah i mean the super bowl is a super
bowl uh being able to go up against one
of the one of the greatest not the
greatest quarterback of all time
in his 150th super bowl i mean it's
going to be a great experience for me i
mean to go out there and get to have a
chance to repeat and get to do it
against the best i mean it's uh it's
something special and i'm excited for
the opportunity
[Music]
i think he's saying tom's old 150th
super bowl that would be a record a
little longer i don't have the record in
fact book in front of me but 150 would
be a record especially since 10 is a
record no one else has more than five
and tom brady's going to number ten and
this is two already for patrick mahomes
at age twenty five and chris
indulge me for a second here i know you
and i disagree about the overtime rule i
still believe that the team that kicks
off should have a chance to match
whatever the team that receives the
kickoff does the rule for a touchdown
does not give the team that kicked off
that courtesy
they took the patriots to overtime
and they never touched the ball i know
in overtime it could be three and let me
just stretch this rubber band a little
bit farther because i hey
in 2017 when they were slumping in the
middle of the season and we were banging
the drum put in my homes put in my homes
put in my homes
if mahomes
splashes in 2017 like you did in 2018
yeah who knows we could be looking at
four in a row and now the question
becomes how many more i mean win or lose
in 13 days
this team is a
machine and it's not just mahomes travis
kelsey incredible tyree kill you know
you don't you don't even get your arms
sore all you gotta do is throw a little
pass and he's got guys twisted and
turned around best receiver the balls
are in his hands it's incredible right
uh well you know that that's what you
love about kansas city and that's why we
sit here and go how long can they do
this because they've realized wait we
have an awesome quarterback and let's
just put amazing talent around him and
therefore his talent even flourishes
even more under in that environment and
that's what we see
i mean hey rough start for the chiefs
yesterday oh shocker i mean
i i don't know
have you ever been less panicked about a
team down nine nothing in a championship
game than yesterday i mean my little boy
there you know he's sitting there
stressed because he's patrick well i'm
going buddy relax this is nine nothing
this is the bills defense this isn't
even tennessee or the 49ers from last
year this will be no problem they're
gonna come back in seven seconds relax
and that's what they did it just yeah
you know bill's played some good
football and were fortunate early on
with the muff punt but
once kansas city got in the groove they
were unstoppable and there was no way
that bill's defense was going to be able
to stop them in any facet mahomes
everybody they got to go and it was fun
to watch i i sense a little sibling
rivalry between your boy phil and your
boy blue
there is
there is my little boy
is truly it's funny because i see this
with his friends too these young
quarterbacks they're so likable you know
whether it's josh allen mahomes uh lamar
jackson baker mayfield i mean i feel
like they just flip-flop between those
four guys all year long it's just
whoever's the hot one of the week they
go to but uh my mahomes just amazing
what we're seeing in front of us right
now he clearly answered the question
last night we love josh allen he's a
superstar he's one of the three best
quarterbacks in football he's not quite
mahomes yet he's not we see mahomes
just the way he can maneuver manipulate
the pocket make every throw in the
history of mankind from every which arm
angle it's very special and he is the
king of the sport
and and here's the thing
that we miss when we compare regular
season mahomes to regular season allen
you don't see play off my homes in the
regular season you get glimpses of him
right in certain games
and this is the reason why the chiefs
are in so many close regular season
games everyone who is playing them is
using the chiefs as the ultimate
measuring stick and the chiefs are just
trying to survive one week at a time you
can't get yourself lathered up every
single week the way the opponent is for
the opponent it's like this is the game
we circled in april we get our shot at
the chiefs so they do what they have to
do to win and they went 15 and well 14-2
they lost a meaningless game in week 17
to the chargers but they they win when
they have to they do what they need to
do but then when it's time
to build your legacy to win in the
postseason that's when they drop the
hammer on you and i think that's
fundamentally the difference to put the
game in a nutshell yeah we saw the real
chiefs yesterday and the real bills
aren't nearly good enough to compete
with the real chiefs no the the bills
are missing
you know the the bravado
the the playoff you know um what do i
want to say battle tested mentality that
kansas city has
and
as we've talked about many times mike
kansas city has a handful of guys not
just one or two guys like j you know
buffalo's got josh allen and stefan
diggs that's great
but kansas city's got a handful of you
know what i just go they're ballers and
what i mean by their ballers i mean when
it's a big moment or a big game they
always pop up and they're all over the
screen and you're just like man they're
good they have players and of course you
hit on the two
tyree kill travis kelsey how special
they are you know we see chris jones all
over the place all night the defensive
secondary he's got guys that rise to the
challenge oh wait you don't think we can
cover this group man-to-man watch us
they're the constant like we don't think
the defense can do that and then they
show us they can all the time and uh
that to me is where the bills need to go
they're missing you know one or two
alphas on both sides of the ball and
it'll change their team to where maybe
next year they can compete with the
kansas city and act and actually beat
them
well and
you know i don't want to get caught up
in
the narrative that you heard at the end
of the game last night if you flip on
some of the other channels you know it's
the and there's a certain element of
pandering to the bill's mafia because it
is a powerful and potent fan base and i
don't want to be on their bad side i
don't want to be on the bad side of any
mafia especially not the bills mafia but
this presumption that i was hearing last
night well they'll be back here next
year they'll be back here next year oh
look at the dolphins oh yeah yeah
the jets are going to start figuring out
with robert sala and bill belichick is
going to have a trip or two a trick or
two up off of his cut-off sleeves i mean
there's
you got to
when the doors open you got to try to
get through it because you never know
when the door is going to be open again
don't just assume the bills are going to
be back in the afc championship next
year they're going to be different the
teams they compete with are going to be
different and they got to go back to
zero and zero and they got to climb out
of it and they're going to be a team
that isn't quite at the level of chief's
measuring stick for other teams next
year but they're going to have
much more attention of everyone they
play they're the top dogs now in the afc
east and they're going to have to try to
get back to that spot
after
reaching that kind of status so i i'm
not saying it won't happen i'm just
saying let's just not assume we're going
to fast forward to the afc championship
and the bills are going to be back
playing the chiefs again next year i
don't think it's going to be quite as
easy for either team but especially not
for the bills
sean mcdermott and we look we we have
said this time and again when it comes
to playing the chiefs you need
touchdowns you need touchdowns
um you can't just keep
taking field goals because the chiefs
are going to score their touchdowns too
many times
last night the bills opted to the field
goal right chris when you've got to
score the touchdown if you're going to
have a chance against the best no i mean
yes yeah definitely
i'm with you there i think though that
just you know the way the game was
playing out and how his offense was
playing in general i think he was a
little scared you know i think he's
scared to you know go for it on a fourth
and two
you know there at the end of the first
half right it's 21-9
the offense had not been good to that
point that was really you know other
than the first drive this drive before
the half where they get the field goal
it's one of the only good drives they
have of the whole first half so i don't
want to continue it i i got the momentum
but you don't play 73 drive get two more
yards i i get it but i also can
understand the field goal at that point
just to go listen we got to go in with
some momentum or something and you cut
it down you know to a nine-point game i
understand i'm not gonna get mad about
not going for it at least at that point
not quite yet not in the second quarter
right there now you want to get into
later in the game when it was 24 to 12
right and it was the third quarter i
believe they have a fourth and three if
i'm yep on the eight yard line you know
there okay that's when i could start
going all right we might need to get
into the time here where it's the third
quarter's coming to an end you got to
start thinking about touchdowns because
your defenses are looking good mahomes
and the offense are a machine at this
point they're moving the ball at five
yards at a time we've seen kansas city's
offense it's grown to where you want to
play these conservative bullcrap don't
let them make big plays defenses they'll
pick you apart so i
mike i get you i i get you i have more
of a problem with the third quarter one
than i do the one at the end of the
second quarter
there's an old cliche that sports
doesn't build character it reveals
character and i think of that because in
these moments where the season is on the
line and everything you've worked for
all year long is coming down to this
that's where who you are as a coach
comes out and that's where you either
act like andy reid did last week when he
went forward on fourth and one trying to
hold off the browns saying there is no
tomorrow or you you get too cautious
yeah you you you you you
you've got to have that ability to grab
the brass ring when it's within reach
arians has it
reed has it and that's one of the
reasons why they're both going to be
meeting in the super bowl in 13 days in
tampa
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports